l'académie parce que ici j'ai appris la
solidarité et des valeurs de savoir être
et de savoir
dalons parce que je veux qui pendant
trois mon internat avec des académiciens
ils y apprennent et passer des limites à
développer mes capacités et mes qualités
l'académie l'aide alors c'est une équipe
qui nous accompagne pour définir votre
projet du coup les notes matière vie
civique c'est un engagement fort et
citoyens qui permet d'ouvrir de
nouvelles perspectives d'ebit entre 18
et 25 ans sans emploi
les passants talent sans repères mais
pas sans envie rejoint l'académie les
dalots renseigne toi et inscris toi au 0
800 801 pouvoir à zéro ou sur
www.nokia.fr le département aux côtés
des jaloux money